[موسيقى]
معنى انقلاب الحاصل في الجابون ومروري
خمسه اسابيع على انقلاب النيجر اصبحت هناك
الان رقعه جغرافيه متواصله من البلدان
الافريقيه من المحيط الاطلسي الى البحر
الاحمر تحت الحكم العسكري وان كانت
انقلاباته غرب افريقيا جاءت في سياق جيو
استراتيجي اكد ان نفوز الفرنسيه هو اكبر
الخاسرين ومن خلفه النفود الاوروبي مع
تنامن للنفودين الروسي والصيني الا ان
الانقلاب الاخير في الجابون بدا مختلفا اذ
اظهر ان احتكار السلطه وتفشي الفساد
وتقويض مصداقيه الحياه السياسيه كفيل هو
الاخر بايجاد المبررات للانقلابيين
وداعمين فكيف تتبلور حاليا مختلف في
المواقف الدوليه من هذه الانقلابات ولماذا
بدات في معظمها مرتبكه نوعا ما واحيانا
حازمه بشان انقلاب ومتراخيه مع اخر وهل
سنشهد مراجعات عميقه لطبيعه التعامل
الدولي عن انقلابات قد لا يكون انقلاب
الجابون اخرها اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم في الوقت الذي كان فيه
المجتمع الدولي يخوض في افضل السبل
للتعامل مع الانقلاب العسكري في النيجر
جاء انقلاب الجابون ليزيد الوضع التباسا
خاصه مع ما بدا من تفاوت نسبيا او كبير في
التعاطي مع مختلف انقلابات بنفس الرؤيا
ونفس المعايير للحديث عن المواقف الدوليه
من سلسله انقلابات في افريقيا وكيف يمكن
لافريقيا واوروبا وكذلك الولايات المتحده
الاعتداء الى مواقف اكثر مبدئيه واتساقا
تجاه انقلابات عسكريه قد لا تتوقف يسعدنا
ان يكون معنا هنا في الاستوديو في هذه
الحلقه الدكتور عبد الفتاح محمد استاذ
الشؤون الدوليه المساعد في جامعه حمد بن
خليفه في قطر من شيكاغو
السفيره الامريكي السابق لدى الجابون
ومنبون الكاتب الصحفي منصف السليمي
المتخصص في الشؤون الاوروبيه فاهلا بهم
جميعا
العسكريون في الجابون اذا اسم بلادهم الى
قائمه الدول التي شهدت انقلابات عسكريه في
منطقه غربيه افريقيا في ظرف زمنيا وجيس ما
يشي بامتداد حاله عدم الاستقرار السياسي
في هذه المنطقه الحيويه بالنسبه للغرب
وبتنفيذ هذا الانقلاب قبل التوصل الى حل
لمشكله النيجر اختلطت اوراقه قوى اقليميه
ودوليه في طريقه التعاطي مع العسكريين
المسيطرين على السلطه في منطقه تتضارب
فيها الاجندات وتعكس حاله عالميه متصاعده
من الاستقطاب الحاد بين الشرق والغرب
الجابون الحلقه التاليه في مسلسل الرمال
المتحركه عسكريا التي عاصفت خلال ثلاثه
اعوام بثمانيه انظمه حاكمه في منطقه غرب
افريقيا
لماذا الجابون ولماذا الان واي مستقبل
للعلاقات مع الغرب ومصالحه في البلد
الاسئله نفسها تتكرر كما في ماري وبوركينا
فاسو وغينيا وتشاد واخيرا النيجر
على ان الجابون ليس حديث عهد بالاضطرابات
السياسيه وذلك رغم حاله استقرار نظام
الحكم فيه ظاهريا بحكم عائله بونجو من عمر
الاب الى علي الابن الذي نسف العسكر
طموحاته لولايه ثالثه في ثلاثه انتخابات
رئاسيه فاز بها علي بونغو عرف الجابون
احتجاجات عنيفه مع صدور النتائج في كل مره
تقول المعارضه ان الانتخابات كانت مشوبه
بالتزوير
الان وقد اصبح الوضع الصحي للرئيس بونجو
صعبه قال العسكر طفح الكيل
حملوا على الاكتاف قائد الانقلاب
الذي اعلن نفسه رئيسا مؤقتا وكما في
سابقات الحاله الجابونيه مظاهرات تؤيد
الانقلابيين في العاصمه البروفيل
يرتب العسكريون الان للمرحله اللاحقه
وتلك مرحله تشكل مازقا للمحيط الاقليمي
الذي ما زال عاجزا عن ايجاد مخرج وسط مع
الانقلابيين في النيجر
ها هو الجابون يضع على الخريطه ازمه جديده
ينتمي هذا البلد للمجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول
وسط افريقيا ايكاس التي قالت ان اجتماعا
وشيكا لرؤساء الدول الاعضاء سيبحث موقفا
بشان الانقلاب لكنها لم تحدد لذلك تاريخا
اما رئيس مجموعه دول غرب افريقيا اكواس
الرئيس النيجيري بولاتينو فقال انه يعمل
بشكل وثيق مع الزعماء الافارقه لاحتواء ما
سماه عدوى الاستبداد المنتشره في افريقيا
على صعيد المواقف الدوليه يلفت النظر
اختلاف حدتها بالمقارنه مع انقلاب النيجر
فرغم ان ما حدث في الغابون ادين من جانب
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي فان
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قال ان الانتخابات
في الغابون كانت مليئه بالمخالفات
وحتى فرنسا التي شكلت المشاعر المعاديه
لها وقودا لتاييد الانقلابات الاخيره
تعاملت بهدوء مع الحاله الجابونيه حتى
الان على الاقل ولم تتحدث عن عمليه عسكريه
محتمله كما في حاله النيجر
وفي الخامس من سبتمبر ايلول من العام نفسه
اطاح انقلاب عسكري بالرئيس الغيني
الفاكونى ووعد الانقلابيون بقياده
بتحقيق انتقال سياسي للسلطان وفي يناير
كانون الثاني 2022 شهدت بوركينا فاسو
انقلابا عسكريا تم فيه اعتقال الرئيس
كريستيانو كابوري وعزله عن السلطه وفي
السادس والعشرين من يوليو تموز الماضي
احتجز جنود من الحرس الرئاسي بالنيجر رئيس
البلد المنتخب محمد بازون في القصر
الرئاسي بنيامي واعلنوا
دكتور عبد الفتاح محمد اهلا وسهلا بك
في انقلاب الجابون بدل المجتمع الدولي
سواء اوروبا او امريكا او حتى الدول
الافريقيه بداوا في حاله من الارتباك على
الاقل في البدايه ما تفسيرك لها
يبدو استاذ محمد انا المجتمع الدولي حاول
ان يلتقط انفاسه مع هذا المشهد الاضافي
يعني هو كما ذكرت انت في افتتاحيتك ان
اصبح هناك حزام انقلابي في منطقه وسط وغرب
افريقيا ولكن بعد التقاط الانفاس يعني 24
ساعه بدات تظهر الادانات التي يعني كانت
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن
الاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك من فرنسا وحتى
الامم المتحده لكن يبدو في هذه الادانات
لا تحمل سوى انه العوده الى النظام
الديمقراطي
ولا تحمل شيء من لغه القوه او التهديد
وهذا الذي يعني يعني يجعل هناك سؤال لماذا
مثل هذا من التراخي في مقابل ما جرى مثلا
في النيجر عندما كانت هناك حده في رفض
القيام العسكريين بالانقلاب
في الحاله الجابونيه هناك انتخابات يبدو
انها كما ذكر رئيس
المنسق الاعلى الخارجيه الاوروبيه كما ذكر
انها كانت انتخابات مشوبه
بفساد مشوبه باشكال كبير
فلعل يعني الغاء الجيش لهذه الانتخابات مع
مرض الرئيس ادى الى نوع من
الخفه او الحذر في تناول الوضع في الوقت
الذي يختلف فيه حال الرئيس محمد مرزوم في
النيجر
الامر الاخر ايضا فيما يظهر النزاع
الموجود على الصعيد الدولي في موارد هذه
الدول
النيجر بلد مهم جدا باعتبار في اليورانيوم
وفي موارد كثيره جدا وكذلك ارتباطه بخط
الغاز الذي يربط في يعني مع الجزائر كل
هذه تشكل اختلافات في المصالح مما يؤدي
الى اختلافات في المواقف السياسيه
الولايات المتحده السيد بن جمالسون في
شيكاغو ادانت طبعا انقلاب الجابون مثلما
اذانت من قبل
انقلاب النيجر ولكن في كلا الموقفين يبدو
الموقف الامريكي وكانه نوعا ما
يعني تسجيل موقف مبدئي اكثر منه شيء اخر
هل هذا صحيح
نعم اولا شكرا على الاستضافه
اعتقد ان هناك
عده طبقات او خطوات من جانب الردة فعلي
واشنطن
طبعا هم من جهه في واشنطن يريدون ادانه اي
انقلاب يحدث خارج السياق الانتخابات لكن
في الجابون في البدايه كان صعبا ان نرى
وندرك تماما ماذا كان يحدث
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده وحكومته ارادت ان تفهم
اولا بشكل افضل ما حدث ثانيا
سيكون من
لو كانت هناك انتهاكات حقوق انسان كبيره
ويبدو ان الفيلجا بون الامر ليس كذلك
الوضع هذا ثالثا لا توجد ازمه وجوديه
مقارنه بالنيجر وبوركينا فاسو فيما يتعلق
بمناطق خارجه عن سيطره الدوله بسبب جماعات
عنف مسلحه واضافه الى ذلك اشعر ان هناك
شعورا بان
الغابون يعني انه وضع ينبغي ان ندينه
وننتظر ماذا سيحدث في المستقبل العاجل
ايضا هذا الموقف المعقد سيد منصف السليمي
لم يحل دون ان تكون المواقف الاوروبيه
ايضا نوعا ما مرتبكه بعد الذي جرى في
الجابون هل هذا
يعني يمكن ان يفسر بشكل واضح
من الممكن ان نرصد مستويين في الموقف
الاوروبي هنالك الموقف الفرنسي البلد
الاكثر ارتباطا بالجابون والموقف الفرنسي
اذان الانقلاب مثل ما ادانه الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن الموقف الفرنسي لوحظ انه كان
حذرا ولم يدعم الرئيس علي بانجو
واشار الى مساله الانتخابات
وتوقف عند هذا المستوى واضح ان الموقف
الفرنسي ربما اخذ درسا من التجربه
تجربه النيجر عندما استهدف الانقلابيون
فرنسا واستهدف وجودها ونفوذها وما زال لحد
الان سفيرها تحت طلب المغادره وبالتالي
فان الفرنسيين يبدو انهم تعاملوا
ببراجماتيه حتى وان حليفهم علي بانجو وقع
عليهم انقلاب يبدو ان الموقف الاوروبي
العام ووراه بالتاكيد بشكل رئيسي المانيا
طبعا عبر عنه جوزيف بوريل منسق له على
السياسه الخارجيه في مستوى اول اذان
الانقلاب وفي مستوى ثاني تحدث على مساله
الانتخابات وقال ان فيها تجاوزات كبيره
وهذا ما يجعل الموقف الاوروبي في الحاله
النيجر وحاله الجابون مختلفتين الاوروبيون
يدعمون الرئيس
رئيس النيجر لانه منتخب بطريقه شرعيه
بينما في الغابون هنالك وضع اخر
الانتخابات مشوبه باختلالات كبيره لكن
هنالك نقطه اخرى عبرت عنها وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه
الينا بيربوك عندما قالت ان العسكريين
ليسوا هم من يصحح المسار السياسي او
الانتخابات بمعنى هنا هنالك نبره اخرى في
الاوروبي لدى المانيا وهي الاعتراض على ان
يكون العسكريون هم البديل عن الاشكالات
التي تقع في المستوى السياسي عموما الموقف
الاوروبي حذر جدا
الاوروبيون مدركون لمخاطر التهديد الواقع
على نفوذ الفرنسي وعلى النفوذ الاوروبي من
ورائهم واعتقد انما ما يرشح الان من
اجتماع التوليدو الذي شارك فيه وزراء
الخارجيه والدفاع الاوروبيين ان هنالك
دعوه صريحه وقد قالها بوريل على هامش
الاجتماع لمراجعه السياسه الاوروبيه في
افريقيا اعتقد هنالك الكثير ما يتعين على
الاوروبيين القيام به في هذا الورش الكبير
لديهم ما يكفي من الاشكالات والصعوبات
خصوصا مع التهديدات
المتزايده من روسيا ومن الصين وغيرها اذا
اخذنا بضروره القيام بمراجعات دكتور
ما الذي يمكن ان يجري في هذا السياق سواء
بالنسبه لاوروبا او بالنسبه لافريقيا او
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده انا اعتقد ان
استمراريه الاوضاع كما هي مع عجز سواء على
الصعيد الاوروبي او الدولي في اجتراح
سياسات واقتراح سياسات يعني يشعر بها
المواطن الافريقي الان المواطن الافريقي
يشعر بتحديات كثيره سواء تحديات ما بعد
الكوفيد 19
سواء تحديات الفقر تحديات التغييرات
المناخ التحديات الامنيه من الجماعات
الارهابيه والمتطرفه
وغيرها كل هذه تؤثر في حياه المواطن
الافريقي ولا يرى حتى نتيجه هذه
الانتخابات او الانقلابات لا يرى هذه
النتائج على وجه الارض بما يمكن ان يحسن
من حياته ومعيشته
فهذا الذي يجعل ربما الانسان الافريقي في
هذه الدول وهي الدول طبعا فيما يسمى
بتقارير الامم المتحده وتقارير التنميه
البشريه هي الدول الاكثر فقرا على مستوى
العالم بلا استثناء يعني ليست فقيره ولكن
غناها لم ينعكس على الناس تمام بسبب
الفساد بالضبط تماما بسبب الفساد على
المستوى الرئاسي مما ادى الى ان حتى
المظاهرات التي خرجت يتم قمعها حتى
الانترنت يتم اغلاق وكان مغلق في فتره
الانتخابات وبالتالي هناك احتقان شديد جدا
وتراكم لازمات متطاوله وكذلك المساعدات
الغربيه التي تاتي من اوروبا ليست مساعدات
موجهه لتمكين الانسان الافريقي وتحول
حالته واحداث تغيير اجتماعي واقتصادي في
حياته مما يؤدي فعلا الى هذه الحاله التي
لا يعرف كيف يستجير من النار الا ربما
بالرمضان وهي العسكريين والانقلابات الكل
يؤكد الدكتور عبد الفتاح بان
الانقلابات العسكريه ليست هي الحل ولكن
هناك مفارقه ايضا هو ان الدول الغربيه لا
ترى مانعا في استمرار الانظمه فاسده وهي
تعلم انها فاسده والحياه السياسيه فيها
منتكسه طالما ان هذه الانظمه قادره على
تلبيه مصالحها لكن بمجرد قدوم انقلاب
عسكري لوضع حد لهذه المصالح يصبح الاعتبار
وكانه مبدئي كانه نحن ضد الانقلابات
العسكريه في حين ان المساله تبدو انها
ليست كذلك بمعنى دقيق تماما 100% هذا
الكلام صحيح هي عباره عن محافظه على
الوضع القائم كما هو دون اي تغيير دون اي
اخلال
بمصالح تلك الدول التي تستفيد من
موارد تلك الدول مثلا الجابون فيما يتعلق
بالبترول البتروليه
واسره البانجو يعني حكمت مده طويله ربما
اكثر من خمسين سنه ولم يستفد المواطن
الجابوني من هذا الوضع في تغيير وضعه كي
يصبح مثل الدول الاقتصادات الافريقيه
الصاعده او الناشئه ومصدر للنفط عدد
السكان قليل ومع ذلك ومع ذلك يواجه
الانسان الجابوني او المواطن الجابوني
يواجه هذه التحديات
فهنا اشكال كبير على مستوى
ما يسمى
حاله التنميه وحاله يعني احداث فرق جوهري
في حياه الانسان الافريقي فيما يتعلق
بالصحه بالتعليم بالخدمات فيما يتعلق بفرص
العمل والشغل وغيرها من الجوانب التي يمكن
ان تحدث تاثيرا او تغييرا اجتماعيا في
حياه المواطن الافريقي فهنا قد يضطر هذا
المواطن الافريقي البسيط في هذه الدول في
حزام الانقلابات هذه الدول الثمان قد يضطر
احيانا عندما يرى انه لا يستفيد حتى من
صوته الانتخابي
وتمثيله الانتخابي على مستوى هذه
الانتخابات التي تمت واوصلت ربما رئيس
النيجر الى السلطه لا يرى تغييرا في حياتي
مما يعني يذهب الى الجانب العسكري وقد لا
يرى ايضا مع الجانب العسكري عندما ياتي
الحكم اي تغيير نظرا لعدم وجود حياه
ديمقراطيه يعني يمكن تنميتها ويمكن
تنشاتها بشكل يستفيد منه هذا المواطن
المراجعه الجذريه التي دعا اليها اليها
بوريل سيد
هل تعتقد بان حتى الولايات المتحده معنيه
بها لماذا لان يعني
لن اعود الى ما حدث في مصر مثلا قبل قبل
عشر سنوات
الولايات المتحده
تؤيد او لا تؤيد انقلاب عسكري بناء على
المصالح وتؤيد او لا تؤيد بقاء نظام معين
بناء ايضا على المصالح فبالتالي الاعتبار
المبدئي هنا يضيع حتى بالنسبه لدول الكبرى
هل تعتقد بان هناك اشكالا يجب حله على هذا
الصعيد
ليس كما يوحي كلامك بالقول دعوني افسر ذلك
من الناحيه الاقتصاديه ويتحدث
الزملاء عن ان البلدان مصالح اقتصاديه
وهذا ما اتفق عليه مع تماما لكن المتحده
المصالح الاقتصاديه تكاد تكون غير موجوده
لا من حيث النفط ولا المعادن
اهتمامنا بالكابون دائما كان مستندا الى
عده امور اولا كانت منطقه هادئه مقارنه
بدول الجوار والوضع السياسي المتوتر فيها
ايضا كانت الغابون تساهم كثيرا في عمليات
حفظ السلام الافريقيه في غرب افريقيا ووسط
افريقيا ايضا كانت الغابون نشطه في مجال
التغيرات المناخيه في العالم هذه مجال
الرئيس السابق بانجو
وحكومته هي سياسات ذات جاذبيه
للولايات المتحده لكن هو واضح انهم لم
يهتموا بالوضع الداخلي والتحسين اوضاع
المواطنين من حيث ثروه البلاد وعائداتها
النصيه كان يقود سيارات فارهه في انحاء
بلاده بينما غالبيه المواطنين يعانون من
عاوز وفقر نحن ايضا تعلمنا عبر السنوات
ومن خبراتنا الخاصه ان لا نحاول
زياده البلدان من حيث ان نبحث معهم بشكل
يملي عليهم سياساتهم الداخليه نحن نؤمن
بالديمقراطيه والدستوريه لكننا لا نريد ان
نكون في موقع يجعلنا ننصح اي بلد حول ما
ينبغي عمله في شانه الداخلي وحتى عندما
نفعل ذلك بصراحه في حالات قليله نحن
بصراحه اقول ايضا نحن في بلدنا الان قلقون
بالانقلابات داخل بلدنا ايضا منذ احداث
السادس من يناير ووجود حاله معارضه عنيفه
في بلدان اخرى
المراجعات التي يدعو اليها بوريل السيد
منصف السليمي ماذا عساها تكون لانه عندما
يتحدث بوريلا على ان الانتخابات في
الجابون شابتها مخالفات وقال بان ما حدث
هو عباره عن تزوير الانتخابات هو نوع من
الانقلاب المؤسسات
ربما ما كان يقول هذا الكلام لو لو الامور
صارت دون اشكال يعني مثلا على سبيل المثال
الاتحاد الاوروبي لم يتخذ موقفا واضحا مما
جرى في تونس مثلا رئيس دوله يصل ويفكك كل
المنظومه الديمقراطيه ويرسي منظومه اخرى
هو ارادها ان تكون كذلك هذا انقلاب
مؤسساتي مثلا اذا اخذنا التعبير الذي
استعمله بورنو ومع ذلك اوروبا لم تتحدث
بشكل صارم عن تونس هل هل هذه المعايير
المختلفه ايضا تعمق النظره السلبيه تجاه
اوروبا
اعتقد ان الاوروبيين معنيون بمراجعه
سياساتهم فيما يتعلق
بالدول الافريقيه في مستويات عديده بدايه
مساله الرابط المصالح والقيم هذه نقطه
جوهريه تؤاخذ عليها السياسات الاوروبيه
والسياسه الامريكيه ايضا
توجد مصالح
تنحدر او ينخفض مستوى حده النقد لتلك
الانظمه حدث هذا مع ما حدث في مصر ويحدث
هذا مع ما يحدث في تونس ويحدث كذلك حتى في
تجاوزات حقوق الانسان في دول العربيه اخرى
ولكن بالنسبه للدول الافريقيه يبدو ان
الامر بات اكثر خطوره بالنسبه الاوروبيين
لانه بات تهديدا لوجودهم وعندما لوجودهم
الاقتصادي والاستراتيجي ونفوذهم ونتحدث
بدرجه اكبر على المنطقه الواقعه تحت
النفوذ الفرنسي هنا فان
اختلالات الكبيره في السياسه الفرنسيه
جاءت بشانها انتقادات سواء من الداخل
الفرنسي ميلانشون وصف ما يقوم به سياسه
الرئيس ماكرون في الدول الافريقيه بانه
خطر على فرنسا رئيس الاسبق هولند قال ان
فرنسا ردود فعلها متاخره ولا تكاد تواكب
ما يجري في القاره
الانتقادات من الداخل الفرنسي وحتى من
رؤساء الفرنسيين سابقين كانت منذ فتره
الانتقادات الامريكيه والالمانيه للسياسه
الفرنسيه في منطقه الساحل والصحراء كانت
منذ سنوات وبذلك بعثت الولايات المتحده
بقواتها ضمن افريكون في افريقيا لتغطيه
الفراغات التي يمكن ان تتركها فرنسا
والالمان دخلوا على الخط في مناطق نفوذ
فرنسيه اقتصاديا هذا كله يدل على انه
هنالك معضله في مستوى اول بالنسبه للنفوذ
الفرنسي وبالنسبه اشمل للنفوذ الاوروبي
اعتقد ان اشكاليه الجوهريه تكمن في
التاليه ان هنالك ديمقراطيات دعمت من قبل
دول غربيه ولكن دعمت كاطار فضفاض دون ان
كاليات للانتخابات وغيرها دون ان تحقق
مصالح الناس الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه هذه
نقطه اولى مما هيا المناخ للاجواء لكي
يكون هذه الموجه من الانقلابات العسكريه
لكن هذه الموجه لا يمكن عزلها عن السياق
العالمي بعد حرب
اوكرانيا في ظل حرب اوكرانيا وحتى منذ
فتره كورونا نذكر ان ازمه كورونا ولدت ما
يشبه ما وقع من انقلاب في السودان
لاقلوس هنا الى فكره جوهريه وهي ان نموذج
الديمقراطيه الغربيه اعتقد انه موضع سؤال
كبير في القاره الافريقيه وان الدول
الافريقيه بدل ان ترتمي في احضان انقلابات
العسكريه او في احضان الروس او الصين
يتعين ان يجري التفكير افريقيين في بدائل
اخرى ذاتيه افريقيه افريقيه لحل مشاكلهم
وهذا السؤال دكتور عبد الفتاح محمد ماذا
بالنسبه للدول الافريقيه لان ايضا لدينا
نزعه ربما تسعى دائما الى انتقاد اوروبا
انتقاد الولايات المتحده ماذا عن افريقيا
نفسها ماذا تفعل افريقيا مجلس السلم
والامن علق عضويه الجابون يفعل ذلك
باستمرار بالنسبه لكل انقلاب ولكن ماذا
بعد يعني مجموعه وسط افريقيا مثلا التي
تنتمي اليها الجابون ربما لم يسمع بها احد
الا هذه الايام مدعساها تفعل ايضا هي يعني
اعتقد كما ذكر الاستاذ المنصف قبل قليل
لابد للافارقه من مراجعه عميقه ايضا يعني
لا يكفي ان تكون المراجعه اوروبيه او
امريكيه وانما ايضا هناك مراجعه مطلوبه من
الافارقه الافارقه قبل عده ربما عقود او
قبل اكثر من عقد تكلموا عن حلول افريقيه
لافريقيا وان لا يعتمدوا على حلول
يستوردونها من من الخارج هذا الامر بقي
شعارا يحتاج ان يترجم على الارض ربما
الاتحاد الافريقي والادوات التي قام بها
من اجل كبح ربما جماح هذه الانقلابات
اصبحت الان يعني حتى الاكواس ومجلس السلم
اختلفوا في موضوع النيجر الامر الاخر
مساله الحوكر الحوكمه الافريقيه
بحلول افريقيه هذه قضيه تحتاج الى يعني
فعلا الى جهد فكري وجهد سياسي حتى ينتظم
يكون هناك منتظم افريقي يعالج قضايا
الفساد والاستبداد والحريات والى اخره في
غياب هذه الحلول الافريقيه للقاره
الافريقيه سيكون فعلا هناك اشكاليات كبيره
كما ان ايضا عندما نقول ان هناك لابد من
مراجعه عميقه اوروبيه وامريكيه
وافريقيه لابد ايضا من مراجعه عميقه لدى
اطراف اخرى تؤثر في القاره مراجعه صينيه
ومراجعه روسيه وغيرها لان هؤلاء كلها
اطراف
تتنافس على موارد افريقيا
الاشكاليه الاخرى ايضا ان
الانسان الافريقي
كما ذكرت استاذ محمد لا يجب ان يتوجه
باللوم ويوجه اللوم الى الاخرين يحتاج هو
ان يقوم بنفسه يعني بالتفكير حول مستقبله
حول رؤيه افريقيه هناك ربما رؤيه افريقيه
20 ستين او عشرين
ربما تحتاج هذه الرؤى
التنمويه لافريقيا ان يتم مراجعتها ووضع
جدااء برامج عمل ومبادرات للتحقق من
تنفيذها لا يمكن توجيها اللون الى الاخرين
وكذلك في نفس الوقت
الحفاظ على موارد للاجيال القادمه في
افريقيا الان انتهاك هذه الموارد بهذه
الكثافه الش من كافه الاطراف الدوليه
الكبرى يؤدي ان لا يبقى اي شيء للمدير
القادم في الجيل الافريقي القادم وربما من
الفوائد السيد ايريك بنجمنسون من الفوائد
الناجمه عن هذه الانقلابات الاخيره انه
مثلا
رئيس السنغال كان يعتزم ان يذهب الى مده
رئاسيه ثالثه تراجع عن ذلك مع احتجاجاته
مع ما حصل من انقلابات اصبح بدوره يخاف ان
يحدث له نفس الشيء رئيس الكاميرون قام
بتعديل واسع وكبير في الاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه هل تعتقد بان
سنشهد في الفتره المقبله الكثير من
التغييرات في افريقيا حتى لا تصبح هذه
القاره فقط هي المصابه بمرض اسمه
الانقلابات العسكريه
اعتقد ان اود ان ابدا الاجابه بالقول
شخصيا انا اميل الى التردد
قليلا
بالاشاره الى افريقيا وكانها كتله قاريه
واحده طبعا هناك افريقيا في الجنوب
افريقيا في الوسط افريقيا في الغرب وكما
تعلمون فالظروف مختلفه واحده من المشتركات
هي المعلومات على الانترنت عندما وصلت الى
الغابون في 2010 كان الناس قد بداوا للثوب
باستخدام الانترنت ولم يكونوا
يملكون في
الاليات عمل ذلك انتقلوا من حاله لم يكن
الاذوهم لديهم فيه ايه هواتف الى الهواتف
الذكيه وايضا راينا في اماكن اخرى في
العالم
هائلا من المعلومات وصل الى شباب
بطريقه لم تكن مسبوقه من قافل الجابون
ايضا التدفق المعلومات الحر بهذه الطريقه
طبعا كان له اثره انتم محقون في القول بان
الفساد هي قضيه
لها اثار بعيده المدى كون ان عائله واحده
تحكم لعقود من الزمن مهما كان الوضع جيدا
يبقى امرا لا ينبغي ان يكون واعتقد ان ما
تحدثتم به عن السنغال
وكاميرون كنتم محقون في ذلك فهم يعرفون ما
يحدث في الجابون
ويعرفون ان اذا ان المؤسسه العسكريه بسبب
الفساد وبسبب عدم اخذه على محمل الجدول
لان
الزعيم رضا ان يبقى زعيما مدى الحياه
فجعلت الناس
يردون ويستجيبون لهذه
الاوضاع من وجهه نظر الولايات المتحده فقط
اضيفه اننا
ان مصالحنا اساسيه ونحن نريد للوضع ان
يكون
سلميا نريد للديمقراطيه ان تكون سائده
ووضع الناس المعيشه جيد وطالما ان مصالحنا
الاقتصاديه صغيره جدا فنحن نود ان نساعد
في عمليه التحول الديمقراطي للغابون باي
طريقه يودها الشعب
الجابوني من طالما ان هناك احترام
للدستور والقوانين اذا نحن في وضع يزالنا
الان نحاول ان نست ما هو المسار الافضل
بالنسبه المتحده ربما ان نستمر على ما هي
عليه الامور ولندعل الحياه تاخذ مجراها
ونرى ما سيحدث هل هذا الاستشراف ايضا وارد
سيد سليمي بالنسبه لاوروبا
في اجتماع طليتنا كان هناك الانطباع بان
ما زالت اوروبا تركز على النيجر وكانها لم
تستوعب بعد ما حدث في الجابون ولم تستطع
ان تتخذ منه موقفا واضحا بشكل لا لبس فيه
هنالك اشكاليه طرحت في اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه ودفاع الاتحاد الاوروبي في
اسبانيا وهي ان جدول عقوبات على دوله مثل
النيجر ولذلك لحد الان
الاكواس لم تحصل على دعما على دعم كامل من
الاتحاد الاوروبي ما زال بشانها اشكالات
هنالك تساؤلات عن فعاليه العقوبات لحد
الان لانه معظم الانقلابات التي او كل
الانقلابات التي وقعت فرضت فيما بعد على
النخب العسكريه التي قامت بها عقوبات ولم
تاتي ثمارها اذا هنالك تساؤل عن جدول
عقوبات هنالك نقطه ثانيه يحاول الاوروبيون
ان يجدوا لها جوابا وهي كيف يمكن نهج
سياسه استباقيه في مواجهه موجه الانقلابات
لكي لا تتسع العدوى من الواضح ان عدوى
الانتخابات
الانقلابات الان هي في منطقه النفوذ
الفرنسي وهي اقل ربما في منطقه النفوذ
الانجلوساكسوني ربما من بين الاسباب حسب
بعض الخبراء الاوروبيين ان في البلدان ذات
النفوذ الفرنسي النخب السياسيه التي تحكم
او العائلات تتسم بفساد شديد ولا توجد
للمعارضه مقومات قوه حتى تصل للسلطه بطرق
سلميه مما يجعل القوى العسكريه هي القوه
الوحيده المنظمه التي تمتلك ادوات القوه
فتسيطر على السلطه بينما في دول
الانجلوساكسونيه مثل غانا او نيجيريا او
سيراليوني او مثل هذه البلدان يلاحظ ان
هيئات المجتمع المدني والاحزاب لديها
هوامش اوسع وربما هنا هذا يحيل الى انه
يبدو المنظومات
اكثر مرونه في التعامل مع مشاكل البلدان
بالمنطقه هذه او ربما بعض الارضيه التي
تعطي افق للتعامل في المستقبل مع الامور
من الواضح ان الاوروبيين الان يركزون على
الفكر الرئيسيه التاليه وهي انهم يريدون
اي لا يريدون ان يلعبوا اي دور مباشر في
الاوضاع سواء تداعيات الانقلابات او غيرها
ويريدون الاعتماد على القوى الاقليميه
المحليه للاتحاد الاوروبي وعلى المجموعات
الاقليميه مثل الاكواس او الايكواس في وسط
افريقيا نعم النقطه التي اشار اليها الان
السيد سليمي مهمه جدا وهي ان ربما وهذا ما
سنشهد ربما في في انقلابات اخرى اذا كانت
الحياه السياسيه في معظم الدول الافريقيه
ليست ذات مصداقيه هناك هزال في المؤسسات
وهناك فساد غياب الحوك يصبح الملاذ الوحيد
او الامان الوحيد هو انقلاب عسكري لكن
الانقلاب العسكري هو نفسه ليس حلا لان
عندما تاتي مجموعه عسكريه
ستفرز فسادها الخاص بها في مرحله مقبله
وقد لا تستطيع وهذه التجربه كل العسكر
الذين امسكوا بالسلطه بعد سلطه مدنيه لم
يفعلوا شيئا اذا هل نحن في دوامه سلطه
مدنيه ضعيفه وفاسده تاتي سلطه عسكريه تريد
الانقاذ لكن في النهايه لا تنقذوا شيئا
صحيح هذه هي الان
المعضله التي يمكن ان نفسر بها ما يجري
لكنه في نفس الوقت ايضا هناك اشكاليه ان
الحلول الموجوده لدى
لدى الاتحاد الافريقي او الايكو اس او بعض
الدول الاوروبيه مثلا ذات النفوس اصبحت
ايضا حلول كما يقولون يعني حلول ضيقه
الافق اما تهديد عسكري بالتدخل واما
عقوبات العقوبات ماذا افرزت الان في
النيجر افرزت ازمه انسانيه واسعه بدات
الامم المتحده تتحدث
ليست حلا فاذا امامنا اشكاليه كبيره
العقوبه ليست حل وعدم فرضها ايضا اشكال
لانه سيكرس الامر الواقع سيكرس الامر
الواقع والامر الواقع الذي يتكرس لن يودي
بنا الى انتقال يعني حاله انتقال ديمقراطي
او حاله انتقال الى الديمقراطيه والى حكم
القانون مما يؤدي الى كما ذكرت يعني
معضله
تدور بها المجتمعات الافريقيه بالذات هذه
التي تتعرض لحزام ما سميناه بحزام
الانقلابات تتعرض لمصير في غايه الخطوره
وايضا لا يجب ان ننسى استاذ محمد ان هناك
حاله دوليه فيها تنافس كبير جدا على
القاره الافريقيه وعلى مواردها خصوصا
الصين وروسيا
ايضا هناك حاله امنيه لوجود جماعات مسلحه
غير رسميه وجماعات ارهابيه متطرفه مما
يؤدي الى تعقيد الحياه من حيث ان الافارقه
يحتاجون من يخفف عنهم هذه التحديات
الامنيه نظرا لما تحمله تلك الجماعات
المتطرفه او الارهابيه من مخاطر على شعوب
تلك المنطقه فنحن امام تحديات فعلا يعني
غير عاديه ومعقده من ضمن هذه التحديات
ربما سيد بنجامنتسون هو ان البعض الان
يخشى مما يسمى بظاهره الدومينو ان تتوالى
الانقلابات العسكريه ولكن هل تعتقد بان
هذا مرجح لان في النهايه اي اي مجموعه
عسكريه الان وقد رات ما الذي جرى لبقيه
العسكر قد لا تقدم بالضروره على خطوه كهذه
من الممكن على المدى او الامد القصير لكنه
ايضا اريد ان اشير الى احتمال الى ان هناك
مصادفه
بسبب تدفق المعلومات
في قاره افريقيا
طبعا
[موسيقى]
نرى ان الانقلابين اقل عنفا ربما في
الولايات المتحده القدره على
التصدي لهذه الامور
وتغيير مجريات الامور والتاثير فيها
محدوده للغايه فنحن نحاول ان
نبقي على نظره متساوقه حول
الديمقراطي اتفق مع
الزميل الذي قال انك من الصعب ام حتى تحول
ديمقراطيا في نظام يحكم لاكثر من ثلاثين
عاما بوجودي فساد هناك احتمال ان القدره
على التواصل بين الشعب ومن المواطنين
تزداد طبعا قد تكون هناك ظاهره دومينوز
نعم لكن اكرر مره اخرى ان القضايا
الشخصيه او المنفرده مختلفه ممكن ان نتحدث
عن احتمال انقلابات في جنوب شرق اسيا
وامريكا اللاتينيه وحتى امريكا الشماليه
والسبب ان الشعوب بشكل عام
تتصرفوا بالشكوكيه كبيره
وتجد صعوبه في تصديقها يعطى لها من
معلومات والجدل السياسي بات اكثر عمقا
واشكاليه طبعا يمكن ان تكون هناك ظاهره
دومنه لكن لا اقول ان هذا امر حاصل لا
محاله سؤالنا الاخير سيد بن جمال صنفي
نهايه البرنامج جوله بين ضيوفنا حول
التوقعات بالنسبه لمسلسل انقلابات هذه هو
نظره المجتمع الدولي لها ماذا تتوقع
تحديدا هل هذا هو السؤال في الجابون وفي
افريقيا بشكل عام
حسنا
التوقعات لدي تشير الى
انه ستكون هناك تغييرات في الحكومات
وان يكون
هناك احتمالات اقل من حصول عنف يرافق هذه
التغيرات وقد تحدثنا عده مرات عن دور
الافراد وعن المنظمات غير الحكوميه
مما يجعلني اعتقد بان الغرب سيستمر
باستخلاص الدرس بان عليه
ان يكون
قللا وان دورنا يبقى محدودا خاصه في
البلدان التي مصالحنا فيها محدوده لاننا
نحن ايضا نبحث عن
الرد والتجاوب مع ما حصل وخاصه في اعقاب
الانقلابات وفي اعقابي ما حصل من تجاوزات
انا لا اقول ابدا بان
الانقلاب امر مقبول لحل المشكلات لان في
واقع الحال علينا ان ننظر الى ذلك بعين
تتجاوز ذلك ماذا سيحصل في
الجابون لو ان الجيش مثلا
حاول تطبيع الامور بشكل طبيعي هذا سيكون
مالا افضل من المالات الاخرى
لكننا نحن في حاله
سيوله والناس ما زال يحاولون استيعاب
المعلومات لهذا السبب اعتقد انه لن يقتصر
على افريقيا فقط بل يشمل افريقيا ضمن
مناطق العالم الاخرى لنرى توقعات منصف
سليمي ثم ن نتهي مع ضيفنا في الاستوديو
الدكتور عبد الفتاح محمد تفضل سيد سليمه
من الواضح ان العالم يعيش مرحله
اضطراب كبير واعتقد ان هنالك ثلاثه عناصر
ستحدد ستكون محددات لما سيجري في المستقبل
اولا ان هنالك عجزا لدى الامم المتحده وما
يسمى بالمجتمع الدولي بسبب
تكثف واحده الصراع بين القوى الكبرى
الولايات المتحده الغرب مع الصين ومع
روسيا خصوصا على خلفيه حرب اوكرانيا اولا
ثانيا بالنسبه للقاره الافريقيه من الواضح
ان الثرواتها والمصالح الكبرى التي توجد
بها ثروات الطاقه والمعادن النفيسه وغيرها
هي بؤره للصراع الحاد واذا كانت القوى في
المرحله السابقه تتصارع بشكل ناعم فهي
الان تتصارع بشكل عنيف النقطه الثالثه
والمركزيه وهي الاوضاع الداخليه في
البلدان الافريقيه ليست فيها تربه وارضيه
ثقافيه ومجتمعيه تؤهلها لقيام ديمقراطيات
او التجارب حكم محلي رشيده بكيفيه تجعلها
بمن اعلان انقلابات العسكريه او التدخلات
الخارجيه ولذلك انا اتوقع ان نعيش مزيد من
المرحله اضطراب وافريقيا ستكون هي المسرح
الاكثر حده في هذا الاضطراب على المستوى
العالمي دكتور محمد
توقعاتي ان الازمات الحاليه
حلولها ليست جاهزه هذه الانقلابات التي
نراها الان يمكن ان يكون في نفس الدول هذه
الثمن التي حدث فيها ان تحدث فيها ايضا
انقلابات اخرى على على النظم العسكريه
بعسكريين اخرين ربما فهذا السيناريو قائم
كذلك فيه هناك دول اخرى مرشحه ان تحدث
فيها
انقلابات والسبب ربما كما ذكر الاستاذ
منصف يعني واتفق معه تماما العامل الداخلي
لا زال يعني كما يعني تمت الاشاره انه
هناك مثلا دول تفتقد الى مجتمع مدني تفتقد
الى صوت صوت اعلامي حر الى اخره من مقومات
التغيير التي يمكن ان تحدث فاذا مع ضعف
مقومات التغيير الموجوده في العديد من
الدول ومع بقاء الانظمه الفاسده سواء كانت
مدنيه او عسكريه سواء وصلت بالانتخابات ام
بالدبابات سنظل نعيش حاله يعني
سيناريو دمينو كما ذكرت استاذ محمد ينتقل
من دوله الى دوله وحتى الدول التي جرت
فيها يمكن ان تحدث فيها انقلابات مره اخرى
وربما الخلاصه ما قاله الامير العام للامم
المتحده قال هناك مشاكل في الحوكمه ولكن
الانقلابات العسكريه ليست هي الحل وقال
بان علينا ان ندفع ونحث الجميع على انشاء
مؤسسات ديمقراطيه ذات مصداقيه ودعم سياده
القانون ولكن هذه معركه ليست سهله ليست
سهله
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عبد الفتاح محمد
استاذ الشؤون الدوليه المساعد في جامعه
حمد بن خليفه هنا في قطر شكرا لضيفنا من
بون الكاتب الصحفي منصف السليمي المختص في
الشؤون الاوروبيه ولضيفنا من شيكاغو
السفير اريك بن جمال السفير الامريكيه
السابق لدى الجابون بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام
نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه
موعدنا يتجدد بحول الله الاسبوع المقبل
وسيناريوهات جديد في امان الله
[موسيقى]